[Music]
I prepared a game one of my favorite
games to show you today and this game
played almost actually over 100 years
ago but it's a very nice game between
last scares and Thomas okay so it's a
very famous game so I like you to know
this game and so I will be asking you to
find this moves so and then after that
we're gonna be doing lots of different
tactics okay discovery attacks double
checks many different type of tactics so
d4f 5 Lasker is playing white and his
opponent is Thomas is black okay yeah so
do you know the name of this opening ah
huh let's see do you know what's the
name of this opening it's not a very
popular opening but sometimes you see
even top players they play this so what
do we do yes it's it's not quite
Sicilian it's it's different a little
bit yeah no see okay let's go over the
Sicilian defense
efore c5 this would be a Sicilian
defense okay so when you see the movie
for c5 then you know this is Sicilian
defense French defense is the opening
that I play my favorite opening but
that's the French defense okay II four
six is the French but I play d4 f5 and
anybody else hopes to try to guess maybe
which opening this is not a very popular
opening but sometimes even grandmasters
play like this so okay so this opening
is called Dutch defense okay so remember
this is Dutch defense
93 white is trying to play efore to get
the control of the center ok now he
plays d6
and now white gets the control efore
takes Knight takes now he plays Knight
f6 now what hitting is the best move
here for white he just developed his
Knight is attacking your knight so you
have a few options here but what would
be your best move here think about it
first
don't rush think about it for a little
bit we can take we can go back with a
knight but in the opening we don't want
to do that right we want to make sure we
are quickly developing all our pieces so
what can we do in this position ok let's
see ok yes you could play Knight to f6
you could play Knight to f6 but see we
exchange and he will develop his queen
so it's possible but you have a better
move here you have a better move here
you could do that but how about trying
to develop a piece can you try to
develop a piece yeah
[Music]
you mean D 3 e 2 after okay well you can
play that that's possible too but
remember in the opening we want to try
to develop the minor pieces first okay
so we try to develop the minor pieces
first and then we develop the major
pieces okay so which minor piece we can
develop here which my minor piece yes
uh-huh
that's the interesting move that's
actually a very interesting move you can
play that move he played a different
move he played a different mo because
it's a more active move okay yeah but
I'm trying to take your night if you go
Bishop c4 I can take it yeah say active
here see okay yes
with bishop yeah we should be theory I
think somebody already mentioned they
should beat it so it's a nice move it's
it's absolutely playable movie should be
three but what would be the most active
move that you can develop a piece and
put pressure on the opponent's position
on which piece you can put pressure now
if you develop a piece correct Bishop g5
very good so you develop your bishop
and at the same time what we call this a
relative pin pin relative pin right if
it was pinned to the king it will be
what kind of pin AHA very good you have
to know this here because we're going to
be doing lots of different tactics after
this game so you have to remember
relative pin absolute pin okay
and in general I want you to remember
very carefully it's a good idea for you
most of the time almost always to
develop the piece and put pressure and
now you pinning him when you develop and
pin it's almost always a good idea for
you okay now of course if it takes the
knight we just take the Queen this will
be very nice for us okay Bishop e7 now
what is block threatening after Bishop
e7 can we just do anything or he's
threatening something now okay just just
raise your hand without making any
unnecessary noises here if you think you
know the more what is the threat yes aha
yes
he wants to take the night yeah because
now he is no longer pinning see he kind
of unpin the pin so now what do you
think I should do in this position
there's so many things to do protect the
night captured the night move the night
so really you have to and some of these
options are playable but what would be
the best yes
capture the night but with which piece
you have two options right you could do
that you could capture with the night
but then we take he takes and it's we're
just exchanging so we don't want to
exchange everything here okay we have a
piece in the center we would like to
keep it but how can we keep that piece
bishop which this bishop no no he's
gonna take you so you need to take this
night okay you need to take the stand
with which piece very good bishop takes
the reason you want to take with the
bishop because your knight is in the
center so you want to make sure the
knight is centralized and putting
pressure okay and now you need to
continue developing your pieces okay now
what would be the next good move here to
develop a piece okay what would be a
good move here
okay yes go ahead yeah
quint were here after yes you could play
that but remember it's very important to
remember you don't want to develop your
queen too early
always remember minor pieces out first
castle after that and only then we
develop the Queen okay at the early
stage it's not effective to develop the
acquaintance be coz minor pieces come
out first safety of the King and then
remember it's something you have to
follow okay yes or you want to castle
this side of the board you could do that
but again I would recommend getting the
minor because usually get your mind
pieces out in order to you know it's
good idea to get a minor pieces out
regardless of where you going to castle
so remember that control the center step
one I think I've told you this before
control the center what is step number
two you remember the five steps yes step
number
uh-huh develop the minor pieces
regardless of where are you planning to
castle develop your minor pieces okay
and then step number three is uh-huh
very good so that's why I would like you
to develop a piece here minor piece to a
good square yes perfect perfect and try
to develop your pieces to a natural
squares yeah I don't want you to put the
night here
put the knight here this is not good
night on a side night you put here will
block your bishop okay so important to
develop your pieces to natural squares
closer to the center okay now castles
now which piece we should develop next
now so we can so we are ready to castle
bishop right
okay yes in the back where do you want
to develop the bishop
okay how many squirts you want to move
the bishop to here you could do that but
you could okay okay let's let's don't
rush let me explain first yeah so if the
bishop comes here it looks like it's
losing a piece but it's not you could
play this move it's not your best move
because after he goes here see you
immediately think that okay this is a
fork but you always have to look at the
moves in between moves so here actually
white can avoid losing a piece if he
takes on f6 with the check and then
takes and then he comes back so he can
actually avoid losing a piece but still
he moves the bishop and then he has to
move again so it's not very good to do
that okay so you want to develop your
bishop but you have a better square that
will help you to attack in the future
which Square is that for the bishop
better square okay yes yeah where do you
want to develop this bishop correct
Bishop d3 this is what he played okay
now he's developing and also aiming for
the attack now he played b6 you know he
should have tried to play 96 this is a
better move so it may be six and here
normally you want to castle but
sometimes if opponent it's not
developing his pieces quickly you want
to try to attack if you can so here
white played a very active move Knight
e5 activating his Queen and also opening
up the diagonal for the Queen to come
here so he played Bishop b7 now we go
Queen h5 now Queen is very active now he
goes Queen e7
trying to defend and now here white is a
very strong tactic I'm gonna be showing
you first okay I want you to pay close
attention I will show you first okay
you're raising your hand you think you
have the move Queen here and if Luke
takes okay that's true but value of the
Queen is how many pounds nine right so
look I you lose nine you take five and
also you lose three so you lose 12
pounds yeah 12 pounds you only get five
so and not so good yeah you don't have a
queen now so here it's a very strong
move here it's a sacrifice in order to
open the position of the king it's a
sacrifice because after that you have a
nice discovery double check discovery
double check first you have to find the
sacrifice so that's a big hint now you
should be able to find the right move
here yes excellent very good Queen to h7
this is what last kill play now he takes
now don't rush we have two type of
double checks here but which one is the
best
okay just raise your hand if you think
you know the move here we sacrifice the
Queen we better have something strong
because otherwise we're going to lose
the game yes that's one of the ideas
that that's a double check - that's one
of the ideas but you have something
better okay something better 9 to g5 but
what will be better to be able to get
something also yes six correct you take
the bishop and double-check I think I
talked about the double check before but
let's see if you know what is double
check raise your hand if you know what
is double check and you can explain
what's happening if there is a double
check remember you have to explain yeah
what's happening when somebody does a
double check okay what's happening yes
you have to move and what is double
check correct so this is very good so
double check is when two pieces shaking
at the same time and in chess you cannot
you cannot block two checks in one move
and you cannot capture two pieces in one
also remember that
so when double check happened it's very
strong one of the strongest tactical
ideas in chess when this happens King
has to move if the King has no squares
to go to what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen
checkmate right perfect but here he has
squares to go to two squares one square
he goes to leads to immediate mate let's
see if you can find it this is a bad
move King h8 checkmate in one now can
you see it okay
yes you see it go ahead checkmate in one
you make one move and you say checkmate
excellent correct Knight to g6 nice like
this are very very strong checking and
controlling see very strong idea so he
has to come up now with accurate checks
you're gonna drive his King all the way
down you're gonna bring the king all the
way here to g1 and then check me this is
one of the one of my favourite games
definitely because it's very instructive
ideas you'll see here now you need to
keep on checking make sure when you
sacrifice your queen you have to make
sure you have some force in continuation
most of the time you have to have mating
threads or keep on checking ok now what
would be the best move here for white
again you have choices and in chess when
you have choices to make sometimes you
make the wrong one so you have to make
sure you can't calculate first yes okay
which Knight we have two knights
excellent
Knight e to g4 check you need this night
here because this site is carding a
crucial square here how many squares you
can go to now how many squares you can
go to how many squares yes to which ones
here can he
aha only one right and that's the square
right he can't go here he can't go here
he came slowly school is here now keep
on checking you have to keep on you
can't give him a break in this kind of
positions you can make like a slow
moving castle you have to make sure you
keep on checking now next again this is
a very famous game 1912 Lasker Thomas
continued ok which pounds we have few
pounds yeah and they can move and you
have to make sure it's a check here it's
a passive possibility but you have
something better because you proved the
point where for I can just take it with
a king so you have something better what
would be the better version of that move
huh which move let's see ok very good
now how many squares you can go to well
if it's zero there would have been a
checkmate one which one well if you
can't take rookies guarding it so you
have to only go here only move now
continue checking ok now what do you do
yes go ahead
correct now Kim comes up to f3
now checkmate in three you're getting
very very close you have many different
checks you must think a little bit here
you have many different checks okay so
yeah but you have to find the right one
here okay let's see
well Bishop before actually would have
been a checkmate but there is a problem
you see the problem with this move see
he takes you so otherwise it would have
been very nice idea checkmate better
what would be a better move here let's
see yes okay I asked him but it's okay
yeah we should be to King g2 now look at
you from here with the sacrifices you
draw all the King all the way here very
unique game you don't see this kind of
games in like once in like I don't know
50 years maybe it's very rare to see
something like this so now checkmate
into your two moves away from checkmate
ink okay go ahead yeah
well the thing is you know he's
threatening to take the rock so if we
move the bishop to have fun he can take
it well you don't want to lose your rock
you don't want to lose your rope because
rook is very valuable piece so you want
to see if you can do something yes
bishop - but again you can take your
rock you have to do something so you
don't lose the rook who can find that
right and the move that doesn't lose the
rock yes correct
now he has only one square to go to to
here and time to checkmate is there a
question or what's the question here how
[Music]
can he can he look at the night huh
and now who's gonna find a checkmate
which will last care plate here huh
there are actually two ways to checkmate
here what did he play yes he castled
very rarely you can castle and check me
see no squares to go to and the second
check man what's the second checkmate
yes absolutely oh you know in fact maybe
in fact maybe he played this move maybe
big that's what it says on the database
but I prefer the long cast but also King
nothing wrong with Hindi - checkmate
how is this a check made because rook is
checking can the King go anywhere can
block can it take the piece that checked
him okay then you cannot do this then
it's checkmate right okay no questions
okay now we're gonna move on to the
tactics okay you know do lots of tactics
today so
okay what I want to do is I want to
start off with a couple of double attack
ideas okay we'll do a few positions on
double attack yesh
so here it's white to play and you need
to find the winning continuation of the
most double attack
okay double attack double threat okay
think about it first they block is up on
and he was thinking maybe I can win this
position I can try to put my rook on d5
and maybe even win the d6 pawn and try
to convert this advantage but not easy
you have to make a move and have two
threats when you read then you have good
chances
okay let's see
everybody should be looking here focus
here and try to find a good move that
creates two threats may be attacking
something and threatening something very
strong okay so that would be a double
attack if you can find something like
that okay we have a couple of hands so
let's see go ahead okay
why is this a double attack can you tell
us
okay so that's one - what's your second
threat your one threat was to take the
rook and second threat is and do a
background check mate
very good good job yeah yeah I mean yeah
yeah I mean yeah I agree yeah but that
will just delay yeah but it's sort of
like yeah you can just delay yeah okay
well excellent very good this is a very
nice move you found because here what is
now an opponent it's not so clear if he
as much but Queen before as you can see
you attack the rook if you win the
rookie will win this game
you'll be up a rock so he can't afford
to give you the rook and he cannot go to
p5 as mentioned because you just take so
he can't just block the Queen be dead so
most likely your opponent probably moves
and then you go check he has to put the
Queen somewhere to block you take
background check mate see it's very
important you look for this kind of
double attack ideas you make a move
double attack not overs you attack two
pieces double attack would be something
like this where do you make a move your
attack and threaten a background okay
okay yeah you have a question about this
position okay
yeah but that's just the one eye one
idea and you're just attacking that's we
couldn't that's not going to be a double
attack because that's just one attack on
the roof yeah with this one what that
pond is protected double attack is when
you threaten two things now it's just
you attacking the rook I will move the
rook then it's you don't have a very
strong follow-up okay you're not tacky I
mean the pawn is protected so you can't
take it you have a question you can move
the Queen to d5 here but then he can't
take okay Ben can you check this guy's
what
well if you go here
no but pond takes yeah
okay sticks okay now so we're going to
move up to the next position again the
winning move here is Queen before very
strong idea okay all right yes
Toby what yeah I mean it could be but
now it's this this idea it creates two
threads okay it's not a fork because
you're creating two threads so attacking
this and you're attacking the rook and
creating Queen b8 okay you're creating
two threads that's what you we don't
have yeah this this is not really a fork
you know because work is when you're
attacking two pieces okay okay
about what no if you're attacking to
pieces at the same time that is a fork
to pieces but here we are attacking one
piece okay
all right we in a piece okay you're not
trying to check my ear
you just need to find a move that will
help you to win a piece in this position
okay
okay white to play
and win a piece now looking for the
checker and winning for that move that
creates an attack on two pieces okay
this idea we can consider a fork to okay
this one this one so let's see okay in
the back yes
okay if you take the pawn but look at
the bishop yeah Bishop we'll take the
Queen so we can't take it yet okay so
you need to do something else here when
you're trying to find the right idea
here first you need to look at the
pieces that are not protected which
piece it's not protected at all here for
black which piece piece which piece it's
not protected at all for black like it's
not nothing is protecting right now
peace peace okay which piece is that
yeah but not upon the peace peace like a
bishop or Knight or Rock not upon ya
pawn we can take but pawn we take we
probably have a little bit of advantage
but we have something better here so
which piece is not protected for
blackish okay yes
you mean the rock that's rook okay very
good
rook on e8 it's not protected and also
the rook on it but we cannot get to rock
on a eight now and also the rook here is
putting pressure on the bishop but it's
guarded by the Queen but you can find a
strong idea here okay let's see if you
have the right move here why to play and
win a piece here you have to see if you
can attack that rook and something else
at the same time that will be a double
attack okay yeah yeah but I just take
yeah I mean you put the rock I take you
take it's like equal trade yeah but
don't trade try to see if we can attack
this without allowing the trade if you
put the rook it's just a trade something
better you have a strong move here let's
see okay yes in the back
Queen goes 3 up here here you're close
you're very close but you have a better
version of that move okay you're very
close but that way you attack the pawn
again in the rook so you need to attack
something else here okay oh you sure you
have it this time
okay go ahead he's got it
very good Queen to a4 why is this a
double attack why you attacking the rook
well the pawn is defended what else
you're attacking it's uh-huh that's why
it's a double attack but it's how defend
it how many times how many attackers you
have now uh-huh two-on-one that means
you can take right so this weekend this
also would be a fork too because we are
attacking two pieces at the same time
nice little move after which you win the
piece okay a question
Bishop platter yes but as I mentioned we
have two pieces attacking when you have
two pieces attacking one defending that
means you can take it yeah so that's why
okay
so again you have to look for this
little moose you know not a long-range
move or anything like a little move okay
you move here an attack yeah go ahead
yeah like let's say we go here he moves
the bishop that is a checkmate yeah
because he can't come up he can block so
that's a checkmate okay very good so the
idea here is Queen 1/4 okay
okay again this is a little bit more
difficult position it's a double attack
again you need to find and involves also
discovery check idea okay like you do
discovery check and you take something
valuable so let's think about it for a
few minutes think about it before you
raise your head just just think first
what can you do here you make a move it
looks like just a single thread but in
fact you have a very strong discovery
that is coming up next so it's a very
strong idea here and when you have a
night like this this idea usually works
so you have to look for that too what
can you do think about it first for a
little bit more
okay first move
aha 97 that would have been four yeah
but what can I do
yeah that's why this idea not gonna work
yeah it just captures with the bishop if
something else here you can try to do
here you make a move and you create a
thread yes
yeah but nine text is six I take it's
like an equal trade yeah you take I take
yeah that's equal trade something better
here in the back yes it's it's white
clay why to play first
if black block is threatening this yes
but it's white to move here white to
move so you need to find a strong move
here yes
aha and if what can I do with this piece
night yeah
but then can I just take that too okay
be careful Quinn is your most valuable
piece if you lose your queen you'd
probably lose the game okay let's do
this let's find a move we play and
create a meet in one thread let's find
that first okay we make a move and
threaten checkmate in one threatening
checkmate in one in one move go ahead
very good
go into g4 when you make a move like
this it's very strong because you're
threatening mate you're not threatening
to win a pawn or a piece you threaten a
mate that means he has to react okay he
has to do something he can't just say
okay yeah you can have the pawn because
that's just a mate mating threat is g7
so he has few options how to defend he
could push he could go back and protect
but it doesn't really matter because
you're gonna do the same idea against
all this moves and I want to see if you
can find the tie that idea it it looked
like it was a single thread Queen g4 but
in fact wasn't because now you have a
very strong idea and you win this game
very very strong idea okay don't rush
that's a good move but you can only win
exchange with that move because I can
take with a queen and then you take my
rock that's good but when you see a good
move you look for a better one
okay okay get some a paper from the
bathroom okay now who's gonna find a
move here you're close but try to see
can you find a better version of that
move you know what can you do here yes
correct
Knight to h6 I know what do we call this
idea what do we call this idea when you
move a piece in check and you attack
something that it was blocking yes
discovery check now this is very strong
check he cannot take because of the pin
he has to go here and what do you do we
take the Queen and we win the game very
strong idea okay very very strong idea
and now you win the Queen so let's go
back and see how this works again when
you have a knight strong knight on a
five you have to try to activate the
Queen and threaten a mate so what do you
do again go ahead
perfect threatening checkmate so he has
to do something to defend the so he goes
here and now
what do you do 9 2 H 6 here don't trash
9 to 8 6 correct check if it a he cannot
take it's a pin so he has to go here
only move and now what do you do
very good Queen to d7 ok very good
ok any questions about this team that we
did today the double double attack do
you understand what is double attack now
when you make a move you create two
threats that's double attack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]